[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
النظام الايراني
الحد الاقصى لسعر النفط الروسي يدخل حيز
التنفيذ اليابان تبدا تطبيق القرار وماسكو
تجهز رده
في المونديال كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان خطف
بطاقتي ربع نهائي من البرازيل وكرواتيا
اهلا بكم
اقرار مؤسسات النظام بالخطا الجسيم الذي
ارتكبته شرطه زهدان واطلاقها رصاص الحي
على المواطنين نهايه الشهر الماضي
في التسريب الصوتي اكد ان الشرطي الذي كان
موجود اعلى مقر مركز شرطه زهدان ارتكب خطا
كبيرا واطلق النار على بطاقه اخرى بعيده
عن المركز قتل على اثره عددا من الاشخاص
واضافت تسريب ان تصريحات مساعد الرئيس
الايراني حول اعتقال من اطلق الرصاص على
سياره عائله الطفل القتيل كيان لم تكن
صحيحه لان الشخص المعتقل مهرب اسلحه الا
علاقه له بحادثه القتل هذا وكشف التسجيل
الصوتي ان 80 شخص لاحتجاجات وجهات اليهم
تهامه والافساد في الارض وقادهر عن
اعدامهم لاحقا
هذا هو كشف تقرير نشره موقعه هونجا هو
لحقوق الانسان عن هجوم وحصار بل عن هجوم
وحصار واسع نطاق لمدينه مرموري في محافظه
ايلام من قبل قوات الامن لاعتقال
المتظاهرين مؤكدا على اختطاف فيما لا يقل
عن 20 شخصا من سكان هذه المدينه من قبل
الامن الايراني امس
واضاف التغير المشاهدين ان مدينه المرمور
كانت مسرحا لهجوم وحصار من قبل القوات
الامنيه على مدار اليومين الماضيين وان
هذه القوات اقتحمت منازل المواطنين
المتظاهرين واغلق المحلات التجاريه
والصيدليات في المدينه
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا اعلنت منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه عن اعدام اكثر من 500
شخص في البلاد منذ بدايه هذا العام وقالت
المنظمه في بيان ان هذا اعلى معدل لتنفيذ
احكام اعدام في ايران خلال خمس سنوات
مشيره الى تنفيذ السلطات الايرانيه لحكم
الاعدام في اربعه اشخاص في وقت سابق في
الامس في سجن رجاء شهر بمدينه الترجي غربي
العاصمه ايران اتهامات تتعلق بالتعاون مع
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
وتستمر موجه الدعوات للمشاركه الواسعه في
تظاهرات جديده تنطلق اليوم الاثنين وتستمر
حتى السابع في الشهر الجاري تحت شعار
انخفاضه ديسمبر ومن الموز مع تنظيم
احتجاجات في اليوم الذي من المقرر ان يلقي
فيه الرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي كلمه امام
الطلاب في جامعه طهران الاربعاء المقبل
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا ايضا من عمان معانا
الصحفي المتخصص في شان الايراني دكتور
نبيل العتوم اهلا بك دكتور نبيل معنا في
هذه النشره ااه مساله حل شرطه الاخلاق في
ايران ربما هي الحدث الابرز خلال الساعه
24 الاخيره هل هي تنازل ام تكتيك
تحياتي يا استاذ احمد جانب النظام
الايراني النظام بدا
يشعر بالرعب وهو نظام مربك في نهايه
المطاف نتيجه لتطور مسار الاحتجاجات
وانتقالها بشكل كبير همم وبشكل غير متوقع
وبشكل العفوي بدون ان يكون هنالك راس لهذه
التظاهرات او الاحتجاجات على خلاف ما جرى
في العام 2009 يعني هو تكتيك من جانب
النظام يستهدف ربما تقديم تنازل
للمحتاجين والمتجاهرين للعوده الى منازلهم
وهناكم احمد ما يسمى بوعود من جانب النظام
بالاصلاح عبر شعار ما يسمى بالتحقيق الامن
اولا ثم الاصلاح ثانيا لكن في نهايه
المطاف هل سوف يعود المحتجون الى منازلهم
كما يريد النظام
الايرانيوم الاثنين يعني هل
اعتقد ونتوقع اذا بناء على هذا التكتيك
امين النظام ان يتزايد زخم هذه التظاهرات
في الايام المقبله اكثر
سوف تزداد خصوصا انه النظام الايراني
تجاهل اسباب هذه الاحتجاجات
وحتى هو في يعني تحليله لاسباب بدا يتحدث
عن ما يسمى بشرديه من خلال بعدين
داخلي العدو الداخلي الذي يثير الفتن واا
يدفع المتظاهرين الى الاحتجاج متجاهلا
بشكل اساسي الاسباب الموضوعيه التي دفعت
الى هذه الاحتجاجات خاصه احنا اليوم نتحدث
احمد عن 40 مليون ايراني تحدث عن 13 مليون
ايرانيه من فقر غذائي بمعنى لا يستطيعون
تامين المواد والسلع الاساسيه نتحدث عن
انهيار العمله الوطنيه
الى 36,000 نت ومن نتحدث عن التضخم حتى
نتحدث ايضا ان الشعب الايراني اليوم
المواطن بحاجه الى 60 سنه حتى يستطيع شقه
حسب حتى اعلان المسلورين الايراني ثم
السرديا الاخرى المتعلقه بوجود عوامل
خارجيه تدفع باتجاه هذه التظاهرات
والاحتجاجات وربما محاوله تنفيذ احكام
اعدام بحق اربع من المحتجين وحتى بالحديث
عن وجود اجهزه استخبارات وتعاون مع
الموساد الاسرائيلي وكل ذلك يعكس احباط
النظام الايراني ويعكس عشوائيه قرارات
اخرى النظام للتعاطي مع هذه الاحتجاجات
بعتقد لا لانه يعني احمد هملجوا الى
الاعتقالات لجوا الى تنفيذ احكام الاعدام
نجاوا الى ما يسمى بيئه تظاهرات المضاده
وفجلوا في ذلك لجوا الى محاوله اعاده او
التعبئه لدى قوات المساج وقوات الحرس
الثوري ودعوه المتقاعدين وهذا الامر لم
يفلح ثم بداوا يتحدثوا عما يسمى بالاصلاح
ضمن سياق اطار النظام الايراني
جبهه اصلاحيه من الرحم للتيار المحافظ
بقياده محمد باقر قريبا ضد متهمه تيار
يسمى التيار او تيار الصمود الذي يدعمه
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي وهذه طبعا لن تنقلي
مثل هكذا دعوات على الشعب الايراني الذي
من هذا النظام السياسيه
احمد التي ادت بايران الى هذا الوضع
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
ايضا التي فرضتها ك ايضا شكرا لك اعتذر
منك هذا ما سمع هذا الوقت وانت معنا من
عمان الصحفي المتخصص في الشان الايراني
دكتور نبيل العتوم تحياتي
وصفا اكراد ايرانيون لاجئون في اقليم
كردستان العراق وصفوا الغاء النظام
الايراني لشرطه الاخلاق بالمحاوله لتحسين
صورته امام الراي العام الدولي كما شدده
على ضروره عدم تاثير الاحتجاجات بهذا
القرار ومواصله العمل لازاله هذا النظام
بوليسيه بويكا
[موسيقى]
برعه او برياني ما شاء الله
اشار المبعوث الامريكيه الخاص الى ان قاده
النظام الايراني سجنوا انفسهم في دوامه
مغلقه بعد قمر
عقد في العاصمه الايطاليه روما انه كلما
زادت مع النظام الايراني ازدادت معه
العقوبات الدوليه وهو ما سيشعر ايران
بمزيد من العزله مؤكدا ان تركيز المسؤولين
الامريكيين يصبوا الان على قضيه قمع
انتفاضه الايراني
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل اتفاق
جديد بين الاطراف السودانيه تمهيدا
للنهائي الازمه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد صورا مباشره
للاجواء الذي تستبق المحاكمه التاريخيه في
بلجيكا لعشره متهمين في تفجيرات مطار
ومترو بروكسل التي وقعت في مارس العام
2016 وطبعا مشاهدينا تفجيرات التي حدث في
2016 هي سلسله تفجيرات وقعت في يوم 22
مارس عام 2016
الدولي كتفجيرين وتفجير في محطه مترو في
بروكسيل في بلجيكا ووقعت هذه التفجيرات
بعد يوم القاء القبض على صلاح عبد السلام
به الرئيسي في هجمات هذه الصور مباشره
لاجواء التي تستبقو بوحاكمه متهمين في
تفجيرات بروكسل اذا ان هذه المحاكمه في
سياق هذه النشره ونشره المقبله
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى سياقه هذه النشره في
السودان ووسط حضور دولي ينتظر اليوم ان
يشهد القصر الجمهوري وتوقيع اتفاق ايطالي
بين المكون العسكري وقوه مدنيه على امل ان
يفضي الى انهاء الازمه السياسيه في البلاد
وتاسيس سلطه الانتقاليه مدنيه الاتفاق
يشهد معارضه من اطراف سياسيه اخرى ابرزها
قوه الحريه والتغيير الديمقراطيه وكيانات
اسلاميه والحزب الشيوعي مراسل العربيه
افاد بان 52 مكونه سيوقعون على الاتفاق
الايطالي اليوم حسب ما توفر معلومات حتى
الان واكد الامير العام لحزب الامه
الواثقه عند الاتفاقات سيظل مفتوحا لبقيه
القوى السياسيه والجماعات الداعمه
الانتقال السلميه للسلطه مضيفا ان حركته
العدل والمساواه والجيش التحرير السودان
المشاركه في التوقيع واشار ايضا الى ان
الاتفاق سيظل مفتوحا في اي وقت تبدي فيه
الحركه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان انفجاري
سياره مخصصه لنقل موظفين تابعين لهيئه
التربيه في الاداره الذاتيه في القامشلي
ومن مرجع بحسب المرصد ان يكون الانفجار
نتيجه عبوه ناسفه كبيره قرب مبنى هيئه
الوزاره في شارع القتل بمدينه
رغم الصغر اعمارهم لا تعرف حياتهم
الاستقرار حتى باتت المخيمات سكنا ووطن
اطفال نزوح السوري في منطقه الباب شماليه
البلاد تقطعت بهم السبل بعد هروبهم من
النزاع المسلح وصولا لمستقبل ضبابيل برفقه
اسرهم خوفا من عمليه عسكريه تركيه محتمله
شماليه سوريا سوريا
[موسيقى]
تتزايد مخوف النازحين في ظل حصار من قبل
مسلحين مدعومين من تركيا
واكراد يقفون في وضعيه استعداد في مناطق
تل رفعت وعين العرب ومنبج شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
البقاء في المخيمات اصبح امنا وامنيات
العوده الى الوطن تظل حلما للنازحين
السوريين الشمالي البلاد لكن امالهم تبقى
اسيره خيام المخيمات في ظل استمرار
التهديدات العسكريه وتصعيدها بين اطراف
النزاع السوري
علي السمان العربيه
كون شركات الطاقه اليابانيه تمتلك حصصا في
مصنع
شرق روسيا في مقابل
الدوليه في بياننا ميخائيل نوف حذر
الداعمين الاوروبيين لوضع سقف لسعر النفط
الروسي انهم او حذرهم بانهم سيندمون على
قرارهم فيما افاد كريم بتجهيزه ردا على
تلك الخطوه سياسيه المشاهدين اكد المستشار
المانيا
على انه من الخطا الفالح حتى توقف تماما
على الحديث مع رئيس روسي رغم كل الخلافات
لقد تحدثت مع بوتين مرارا وتكرارا منذ ذلك
الحين لانني مقتنع تماما بانه من الخطا
الفاتح ان لا نتحدث مع بعضنا البعض على
الرغم من كل الاختلافات ولهذا السبب من
المهم ايضا ان نواصل انا والرئيس الفرنسي
بصفاتنا ممثلين لدول مجموعه العشرين وبصفه
دولتين في حلف شمال الاطلسي السعي الى
الحوار مره اخرى ولكن يجب دائما توضيح هذه
النقطه بوضوح شديد ويجب معالجه الدمار
الرهيب الذي تسببه الصواريخ الروسيه
للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه واوكرانيه
الاستخبارات الوطنيه
ويشير الى ان القوات الاخاريه قد يكون لها
افاق اكثر اشراقا في الاشهر المقبله
من ماسك مشاهدينا محلل السياسي
الانديه معنا في هذه النشره كما تبعنا فان
قرار الدول الاوروبيه بوضع سقف للنفط
الروسي سيدخل حيز التنفيذ اليوم طبعا
الاكثر من 60 دولارا
ما هي خيارات موسكو للتعاطي مع هذه الازمه
الجديده
كما تفضلتم الدول الاوروبيه اعطت لي روسيا
خيارات هذا النقطه المهمه جدا وخيارات
ويبارك قويه
سابقا
الى الدول التي وضعت هذا السقف في حال
كانت الاعصار
منخفض مقارنه مع الاسعار في اسواق الحره
في نفس الوقت همم
الدول الاوروبيه لا تتخلى عن الروسي بشكل
كامل فهذا يعتل روسيا همم خيارا اخرا
فروسي يمكن ان تستعمل هذا الخيار في حال
توافق ذلك بالمصالح السياسيه والاقتصاديه
همم
لذلك من جديد يقول هي ورقه قويه في همم
دروس يعني دائما ان في السابق بان روسيا
همم
الاتهامات الروسيه تستعمل للغاز همم حاليا
همم الاوروبيه اعطت لي روسيا وورقه قويه
لكي يمكن ان تستخدم
روسيا تستخدم هذه الورقه سيد الاندري من
دون ان تتاثر وهي تعتمد بشكل كبير في
وارداتها الماليه وفي توفير امكاناته
الماليه على النفط بالتاكيد على الغاز
ايضا
هذا صحيح من جهه من جهه اخرى نحن نشاهد
زياده استيراد النفط الروسي من قبل الصين
والهند خاصه الهند التي اصبحت تستورد
النقطه الروسي بالكميات غير المسبوقه في
نفس الوقت روسي يمكن ان تقطع الدول
الاوروبيه عن امدادات
في هذه في هذه السنه نحن ربما ايضا
مجموعه اوكلاس
لترتيب الامور في اسواق النفط الاعلاميه
لوضع الاستقرار في اسواق النقل الاعلاميه
ولكن بالنتيجه لا تنسى
ستكون المستفيده من روسيا ستكون المستفيده
جدا الاورو
ايه سبب لما قامت بمثل هذه ولكن حتى الدول
التي اشرت اليها وانا اعني هنا الهند
والصين مثلا هي دوله تتعرض بالتاكيد لضغوط
الاوروبيه لتنفيذ هذا القرار هل تتوقع
انها يمكن ان تردخ لهذه الضغوط استنادا
على لعبه المصالح والفراغماتيه التي تحكم
علاقات هذه الدول
اولا انا اعتقد ان الهند والسين كما
تفضلتم ما تتمسكان بفكره البرغماتيه هذا
الشيء همم اكبر التساؤلات كانت حول الهند
بصراحه ولكن في السابق انه سامعنا ان همم
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانها
توافق على همم يمكن ان تصدر الهند همم
القضايا النفسيه بنزين والمخلوقات الاخرى
مصروع من النفط الروسي لا تمنى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لذلك همم من هذه وجهه
النظر عن اعتقد ان تكون هناك اي مشاكل
في موازنه هذه الاجراءات همم الاوروبيه
ربما تكون قاسيه على موسكو لكن هناك ايضا
لغه مهاد اخرى تحدث بها الرئيس الفرنسي
الى الرئيس الروسي الخاصه فيما يتعلق
بمشكله او ازمه التوسع هل همم هذه الخطوه
من الرئيس الفرنسي بشيء ما
هذا السؤال جي جدا حاليا نحن بنسمع كثير
من الكلمات تصريحات الوقت لاخر حتى
تصريحات متضاربه يمكن ان نقول ان روسيا من
حيث الحوار طبعا مكرونه حاليا يتحدث بانه
يمكن ان يحترم المخاوف الروسيه الامنيه
نفس الوقت نحن نصنع المطالب لانسحاب
الروسي من الاراضي التي تعتبرها الدول
الغربيه
الجديده التي انضمت الى صفوف الاراده
الروسيه المؤخرا وكذلك
لما نحن حاليا بعض المناورات من قبل العيد
ولكن
بعيدين جدا عن التفاوض الحقيقي ما بين
روسيا وامريكا وما بين روسيا واوكرانيا
شكرا لكم
مع استمرار انقطاع الكهرباء والماء في
اوكرانيا بسبب القصف الروسي اعتاد السكان
التردد على المقاهي والمطاعم للحصول على
شيء من الطاقه تساعدهم في تعويض ما
يفتقدونه في منازلهم التي يخيم عليها
الظلام والبرد
تحديات الحرب في اوكرانيا كثيره بسبب
اصرار موسكو على تدمير بنيتها التحتيه
ابرزها بالنسبه للاوكرانيين الكهرباء
والماء مع دخول فصل الشتاء فارس في
العاصمه كيف التي لم تتوقف روسيا عن
استهدافها
باسعمالكم مقها الى توفير شيء من الدفئ
والضوء لزبائنه وما تيسر من خدمات
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وعدم توفر خدمه
الانترنت نفقد نحو 70 في المئه من رواد
المقهى
المشهد في المقاهي يقابله اخر في بعض
المطاعم والمنازل يعول من خلاله
الاوكرانيين على مولدات الكهرباء للحصول
على الطاقه
على 10 ساعات مع توفر البنزين تساعدنا على
تقديم الشاي والقهوه
الخدمات في المقاهي وان كانت بسيطه لكنها
تساعد كثيرين في الحصول على خدمات
الانترنت بينهم طلاب الجامعات مما يفتقدون
وسائل الراحه في منازلهم
الى انجازها وتقديمها باسرع وقت بالاضافه
الى الدراسه لذلك اتردد على المقهى
ومع استمرار روسيا في استهداف مواقع
الطاقه الاوكرانيه واتهام كيبلي موسكو
باستهداف المدنيين وحرمانهم من الكهرباء
والماء اصبح المشهد والمعتاد في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه تعلوه اصوات المولدات ورائحه
البنزين رغم شرحه لدفع عجله الحياه
اليوميه
جاسم محسن العربيه
النظام الايراني يعترفوا بقتل المتظاهرين
عشوائيا وتراقب لموجه جديده من الاحتجاجات
وسط حضور دوليه واقليميه توقع بعد قليل
الاتفاق الايطالي
تبدا تطبيق القرار
في المونديال كوريا الجنوبيه
من البرازيل وكرواتيا
اهلا بكم 2016
ولا مشاهدين الى اخبار الرياضه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله الى الموجز الرياضي المنتخب
الانجليزي عقبه السنغال نحو دوري الربع
النهائي بفوزه عليه بثلاث اهداف من دون رد
ليضرب موعد مع المنتخب الفرنسي في مباراه
المثيره المرتقب وجاء هدفه الانجليزي
الاول عبر لاعب الوسط هندرسون في الدقيقه
38 من عمر الشوط الاول يحتفل بهدفه الاول
في كاس العالم قبل ان يفك اخيرا هاري كين
صيامه عن التهديد ويسجل هدفه الشخصيه
الاول في هذه المسابقه والثاني لمنتخب
بلاده في هذه المباراه عند الدقيقه
الخامسه والاربعين ومنح بوكا والهدف
الثالث عند الدقيقه الثامنه والخمسين
ليؤكدته بالوصول الى دور الثمن
[تصفيق]
وقد النجم كيليان مبابي منتخب فرنسا
للعبور الى دور ربع النهائي بعد ما سجل
هدفين في شباك بولندا في المباراه التي
انتهت بثلاثه اهداف دون مقابل لصالح منتخب
بلاده
ونجحو بتسجيل الهدف الاول لمنتخب فرنسا في
الدقيقه 44 والذي اصبح به الهداف التاريخي
لمنتخب الديوك برصيد 52 هدفا
متخطياري قبل ان يضيفه هدفين متتاليين كان
الاول في الدقيقه 74 فيما جاء هدفه شخصيه
الثانيه عند الدقيقه 90 وسجلت بولندا هدفا
وحيدا عبر ليفاندوفسكي من ركله جزاء كان
في الدقيقه التاسعه من الوقت المضاف على
المضاف
وتسع البرازيل لتجنب المفاجات عندما تلتقي
امام كوريا الجنوبيه وكان المنتخب
البرازيلي قد تعرض لهزيمه مفاجاه امام
الكاميرون في الجوله الثالثه من دوري
المجموعات بينما تاهلت كوريا الى الادوار
الاقصائيه بعد تحقيقها فوزا المستحقا امام
البرتغال بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد وتعد هذه
المباراه هي الاولى بين المنتخبين في اطار
نهائيات كاس العالم
كشف تاتي مدرب البرازيل لان نيمار سيشاركم
مع المنتخب الوطني في مباراه دوري 16 لكاس
العالم لكره القدم امام كوريا الجنوبيه
الاثنين وتلقى المدافع سؤال في مؤتمر صحفي
بشان امكانيه مشاركه نيمار في المباراه
لكن التي امسك بالميكروفون ورد بالاجابه
نعم اخذ نيمار سباقا مع الزمن حتى يكون
جاهزه عقب اصابته في الكاحل امام الصربيا
في اولى مباريات منتخب بلاده ضمن المجموعه
السابعه
صديق
لا افكر حاليا سوى بهذه المباراه واعرف ان
الخصم مرهق بعد المباريات التي لعبها
اليكساندرو لن يكون جاهزا للمشاركه ولا
يمكن التسبب بتفاقم اصابه اي لاعب ما
قدمناه خلال دوري المجموعات من اداء
واهداف هو نتائج التدريبات التي خدناها
على بناء الهجمه وكيفيه الوصول الى المرمى
حلل المنتخب البرازيلي في مختلف المباريات
ونعرف نقاط القوه لديه اللاعبون يعرفون ما
هو المطلوب منهم امام فريق مثل البرازيل
مواجهه البرتغال ارقتنا بدنيا ومعنويا ولم
نتدرب لمده يومين هو حمل كبير علينا
التعامل معه بينما ارحل البرازيل النجوم
في المباراه الثالثه
ويلتقي المنتخب الياباني امام نظيره
الكرواتي ضمن منافسات دوري 16 من منافسات
كاس العالم لكره القدم وخلق الساموراي
المفاجاه بتصدر مجموعته امام منتخبات
كبيره مثل اسبانيا والمانيا من جانبه بين
وصيف النسخه الماضيه كرواتيا يسعى لمواصله
مشواره في البطوله بعد ان حلف المرتبه
الثانيه خلف منتخب المغرب في المجموعه
الثالثه
عاليه الان ونؤمن بانفسنا وبامكاننا الفوز
على كرواتيا حتى الان لم تتمكن الكره
اليابانيه من الذهاب ابعد من ثمن النهائي
شاركت في اربع بطولات كاس عالم ووصلت الى
الثمن النهائي مرتين اتمنى ان نكون في
يومنا امام كرواتيا وان نكتب تاريخا جديدا
لبلادنا في النهائيات
انشطه
لقد عبرنا دور المجموعات وهو وصلنا الى
دور 16 هذا امر جيد نحن موجودون هنا
لمواجهه السعه سنفعل ذلك هذا حلمنا كما
تعلمون لكننا سنتخذ خطوه واحده في كل مره
نحن بحاجه الى التحلي بالصبر الاهم مباراه
اليابان وبعد ذلك سنرى اذا كنا سنذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار المونديال شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفيه الرياضيه
اشرف محمود اهلا بك سيد اشرف معنا في هذه
النشره دعانا نبدا بالبرازيل وكوريا
الجنوبيه ما الذي ينتظره من هذا اللقاء
خاصه على مستوى الاداء
والزخمه التي تسببه عوده نيمار
في كل مكان في العالم العربي وكل العالم
المباريات دخلت مرحله الجده وربما مباريات
المجموعات او المجموعه او الدور الاول هي
مباراه تعويض لديها لديك فرصه للتعويض لكن
مباريات دور ال16 وما يليها من مباريات
حتى النهائي ليس فيها تعويض الخاسر يودع
تماما ويستقل الطائره عائدا الى بلاده
المباراه التي تجمع همم السامبا مع شمشون
الكوري مباراه صعبه على الطرفين الكوريون
يتمتعون بالياقه بدنيه عا- عاليه ويتمتعون
بالسرعات ويتمتعون بالعمل الجماعي هم فريق
جماعي ليس فيهم الا نجم واحد اللي هو
هيوندا الذي يلعب في توتنهام ومسجل ثلاث
اهداف في المقابل المهاره والمتعه
والاثاره موجوده مع الكره البرازيليه مع
السامبا البرازيليه راقصه السامبا
يستطيعون ان يقدموا ملامح فنيه تبهر
الجميع المدرجات في الملعب ستكون اغلبها
مع البرازيل لان المجموعه العرب دائما
يعشقون الكره البرازيليه اذا هي مواجهه
صعبه خصوصا وان الفريق البرازيلي خسر
مباراته الاخيره حتى وان كان خسران امام
الكاميرون بفعل انه اراها عدد كبير من
لاعبيه تيتي لكن المدرب همم بنته المدير
الفني لكوريا الجنوبيه يعني استبعد
المقارعه نتيجه يعني 72 ساعه فقط فاصل ما
بين مباراه همم ختام الدور الاول ومباراه
دور ال 16 قال البرازيل راحوا لاعبين
لكننا لم نكن بهذه الرفاهيه كان علينا ان
نفوز على البرتغال وبالتالي لاعبنا من اجل
الفوز وهو ما كان نيمار تعتقد انه سيكون
كلمه السر في مباراه اليوم
ان لعب نيمار كما قال برضو بنته قال
معلومه جميله جدا قال لك نحن لا نستطيع ان
ننكر اننا سنخشم وجود نيمار في الملعب لكن
نيمار لا اعتقد انه بكامل الجاهزيه وربما
ياخذ جزء من المباراه لكن وجوده داخل
الملعب طبعا يثير قلق لدى الكوريين لاعب
زوماره عاليه وقدره فنيه كبيره وخبرات
متميزه وجوده في الملعب حتى ولو بنصف همم
لياقاته البدنيه او نصف همم
استعداداته اللوجستيه لكنه فنيا يستطيع ان
يعوض وجوده يزعج مدافعي همم كوريا
الجنوبيه طيب وبالنسبه لكوريا الجنوبيه
همم وهي طبعا المنتاشيه بوصلها لتوم
النهائي كيف لها ان تلعب اليوم بطريقه
الدفاعيه ام هجوميه في رايك لحمايه عرينها
من العراق
بالفعل كما ذكرت انت ستبدا بما ذكرته وما
ختمت به كلامك ستلعب دفاعيا تامين دفاعي
ممتاز تقارب في الخطوط ما بين الوسط
والدفاع على وجه الدقه الاعتماد على هيونغ
في المقدمه الهجوميه للكرات المرتده
السريعه ساعتمدون على السرعه لكن التكتل
بجدران بشريه امام المرمى سيكون متواجد من
وسط الملعب مع المدافعين لانه كلما مضى
الوقت باتجاه نهايه المباراه واللاعب
الوقت اضافي او همم ركلات ترجيح سيكون
حظوظ الكوريين اعلى مع انفسهم لكن
البرازيل يعني سيفطن تيتي لهذه النقطه
وسيحاول ان يستخلص بمهارات لاعبين همم
يعني كما حصل مع مبابي وكين بالامس همم
مهارات لاعبين وايضا ميسي مهارات لاعبين
صنعت الفارق باقل التفاصيل طيب كل هذه
لقاءات اليوم شكرا لك من القاهره كنت معنا
الصحفي الرياضي اشرف محمود السيد اشرف
بينما تشعل المنافسات الكرويه بمسابقه كاس
العالم لكره القدم المقامه حاليا في قطر
يقف عشاق هذه الرياضه في روسيا على رصيف
الحرمان من هذه من هذا العرس عفوا الكروي
بعد منعهم من خوض المنافسات المؤهله
للنهائيات بسبب العقوبات الغربيه
[موسيقى]
الشتوي في وقت تتعلق فيه عيونه عشاق
المستديره بملاعب قطر وبطولتي كاس العالم
وعلى بادي بضعتك كيلومترات يبدو المشهد
ومختلفا كليا في شوارع المدينه حيث لا
يمكن للمرء تصديقه ان كره القدم هي اللعبه
الشعبيه الاولى في بلاد الثلج
الروسي الذين كانوا البارحه يرحبون على
ارضهم بضيوف النسخه الماضيه يعرفون جيدا
لذه اجواء كره القدم وما تحمله من اثاره
لكن تعاملهم مع نسخه قطر مشحون بالخيبه
والغيره والحسد خاصه مع نيلهم البطاقه
الحمراء من التصفيات المؤهله للمونديال
بسببي عقوبات الفيفا
المنتخبات العربيه
قلبنا كان مع الاخضر السعودي والان مع
المغرب وبالطبع مع حليفنا صربيا
كاس العالم عندما تلعب روسيا فقط اما الان
فلا اهتم
[موسيقى]
صراع موسكو مع الغرب ذهب بالاتحاد الروسي
لكره القدم للبحث عن تحويل عضويه البلاد
الى الاتحاد الاسيوي علما ان لدى موسكو
حتى الان فرصه محتمله للمشاركه في تصفيات
اليورو القادمه حسب روايهتهم عبد الجواد
الروشد العربيه مصر
المشاهدين في تونس قراره الغرفه النقابيه
المؤسسات الصيدلانيه وقفه تزويد الصيدليه
بالادويه بدءا من اليوم الاثنين
توزيع الادويه في البلاد والحفاظ على حق
المرضى في الحصول على الدواء
الاحد هو يوم عطله في تونس تتوقفوا بموجبه
جل الانشطه في البلاد الصيدليات بدورها
تخضع لهذه القاعده ويغلق معظمها ابوابه
لكن هذه المره قد يتواصل هذا الاغلاق الى
اجل غير مسمى بسبب قرار موزعي الادويه
بالجمله ايقاف تزويد الصيدليات بالادويه
هذا الاعفاء يعطى لهم من سنه 2006 لكن سنه
2022 وزاره الماليه رفضت اعطاء هذا الوفاء
مما قد يسبب لهم حجز في السيوله الماليه
قد يقدر 50% من هذا القطاع الى الافلاس
نقابه موزعي الادويه بالجمله تؤكد ان قرار
يعود الى عدم التوصل الى حلل وعدم تجديد
شهاده خصم من المورد للمؤسسات الموزعه
للادويه بالجمله على ما بيعات الادويه
للسنه اثنتين 22
ونظرا للارتفاع المتواصل للاعباء الماليه
لهذه المؤسسات ما يتسبب في ازمه خانقه
وضعيه تضرر معها نشاط الصيادله واشتكى
منها المواطن ضرر في النشاط ثم ضرار في
همم
فريده بتوع التزاوج ويخلينا نخموف
النهارين الجايين زيد القدام نقرا حسبنا
من توه مش من
نصر والادويه المطلوبه والكل
عنه وقبل في نقص في المواد الغذائيه
ثم الناس
الماليه
توقف النشاط التي
والتي تنطلق من اهتراء البنيه التحتيه
الصحيه ولا تتوقف عند تدني الخدمات الصحيه
ونقص الادويه ما يجعل جل المرضى يكافحون
بلا سلاح ضد الامراض وخاصه الخطيره
والمزمنه منها وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
وفي العراق ايضا يواجه المرضى نقصا حادا
في الادويه داخل المستشفيات الحكوميه بعد
سيطره الاحزاب والمرشات على سوق العقاقير
الطبي واحتكار بيعها واستاراتها الامور
الذي ادى الى زياده الجنوبيه في اسعار
الادويه
نقص الادويه في العراق لا يقتصروا على نوع
محدد فالمستشفيات والحكوميه عجزه عن توفير
قائمه طويله على راسها ادويه مرضى السرطان
الذين باتوه مجبرين للبحث عنها في السوق
السوداء للحصول عليها باسعار باهظه جدا
بايش الادويه من بره غاليه ب 50 وب 40 و
60 و100 واحنا احنا ناس ما عنده القطاع
الخاص
80% من سوق العقاقير الطبيه في العراق
والتي يدخل معظمها الى داخل البلاد بطرق
غير قانونيه
هذا الاحتكار ادى الى وفاه العشرات يوميا
في المستشفيات
بسبب ارتفاع اسعار هذه العقاقير ومع الاسف
على حكومه اللي عدم المتابعه للصيدليات
وازيد الناس تعبانه
والمستشفيات عدم توفر الدواء بيها
فالمواطن وين يطر يروح يطري يروح علما
للخاص رغم حملات التفتيش التي نفذتها
وزاره الصحه والاجهزه الامنيه لعدد من
مداخر الادويه والصيدليات التي تحتقر بعض
العقاقير الطبيه الضروريه الا ان ذلك لم
يوفر حلا لهذه المشكله ولم يوفر الدواء
لمحتاجين من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه
زيانت ريشه رسام في قريه بيبان في مدينه
نينوى اثريه شمال العراق الجدران برسمات
تحمل في طياتها رسائل تدعو الى احياء
التراث الحديدي الذي يواجه حمله اباده
قادها عناصر تنظيم داعش في الثالث من
اغسطس العام 2014
[موسيقى]
من الداخل شواهد الجدران زينت برسمات فنان
تدعو الى احياء التراث الايزيدي وتزيين
مدينته جدران زينتها ريشه رسام
تهدف في تفاصيلها الى تعريف الاجيال
الجديده بتاريخ المدينه لا نسيانه والمرور
منه هنا الساحه الرئيسيه للقريه وبين
جدرانها زينت رسمات اثريه وهي ساحه تقام
بها الاحتفالات الدينيه وحفلات الزفاف
لاهالي القريه
ريشه الفنان العراقي فارس بيباني الذي
يقضي الجهد والوقت لايصال رسائله للاجيال
القادمه
وذكرت ان هذا الفن يحمل رسائل عده من طيات
الماضي
واللي
بزمننا واللي بعمرنا احنا شفنا ااا
هوايه امور قديمه يعني يعني لحقنا عليه بس
اكو شباب
ارسم واشرح لهم قبلكم
الفنان العراقي فارس بيباني
في جرائم الحرب عينتها الامم المتحده
بانها اباده جماعيه ضد الايزيديين الذين
ارتكب تنظيم داعش في الثالث من اغسطس عام
2014 بحقهم اقصى الفضائح والانتهاكات
اضافه الى اجبارهم على القتال في صفوفه
ويعود اصل الايزيديين الى مجتمع ديني يضم
400 الف شخص في شمال العراق قبل ان
يتعرضوا لحمله اباده قادها عناصر داعش
نشاهد مشاهدينا صورا لانطلاق محاكمتي
بروكسل التي وقعت في مارس العام
2016 واسفرت كذلك عن مقتل اثنين وثلاثين
شخصا واصابه اكثر من 300 اخرين المتوقع
مشاهدينا ان يبدا المبدعون قراءه رائحه
الاتهام المكونه من 400 وسته وثمانيه صفحه
غدا الثلاثاء قبل بدء جلسات الاستماع لنحو
300 خبيرا وشاهدا اذا ان هذه الصور
المباشره مشاهدينا الانطلاق محاكمه
المتهمين في تفجيرات مترو ومطار
لو في ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
نذكروا بابرز العناوين
النظام الايراني
عشوائيا وترقب لموجه جديده من الاحتجاجات
وسط حضور الندى واقليمي الاطراف السودانيه
توقع بعد قليل اتفاقا ايطاليا يمهد لانهاء
الازمه
الحد الاقصى لسعر النفط الروسي يدخل حيز
التنفيذ اليابان تبدا تطبيق القرار وماسكو
تجهز ردا
في المونديال كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان تام
خطف بطاقتي ربع النهائي من البرازيل
وكرواتيا
[موسيقى]